things are never gonna be the same now I
mean look at this got aliens you have
big green guys turns out buildings right
as a kid I used to draw cowboys and
Indians um actually it's Native American
but yeah tell you what though that bad
is it
no yeah kids go to the future
[Music]
oh hey you can't saw through that stuff
these alien bastards are tough you got
to use the stuff they use Hey
glad you to join us afternoon my long
been gone yeah yeah yeah your long look
just go smack that armor plating like I
asked this is a huge deal for us
Tan Cheng please in accordance with
executive order two three nine six be
all post battle cleanup operations are
now under Howard jurisdiction thank you
for your service we'll take it from here
well how are you qualified listen um
look I have a city contract to salvage
all this okay with the city so apologize
mr. tombs but all salvage operations are
now under our jurisdiction please turn
over any and all exotic materials that
you've collected or you will be
prosecuted man trucks for this job
I don't know crew these guys have a
family I have a face my house I'm sorry
sir there's nothing I can do maybe next
time don't overextend yourself what you
say yeah he's right i overextended
myself what I'm down if you have a
grievance you may take it up with my
superiors this appears who they are a a
joint venture between Stark Industries
and the federal government the
Department of damage control will
oversee the collection and storage of
alien and other exotic materials so not
[__] who made this mess again paid
the tri-state area hey chief we just
love another load from yesterday
you're supposed to turn this in right oh
you know I'll win it it's too bad it
could have made some pretty cool stuff
from all that alien junk
I'll tell you what let's keep
world's changing it's time we change too
[Music]
there you go Mason business is good
New York Queens
it's a rough pour over hey it's home are
you talking to no one just making a
little video of the trip you know you
can't show it to anyone yeah no don't
worry narrating in that voice Oh cuz
it's fun fine so what they call you
happy come on I'm not carrying your bags
go hey should I go to the bathroom
before there's a bathroom on it
whoa no pilot that's awesome oh is that
we gonna sit yeah is your first time on
a private plane what's on anything
should it be we should have been making
that noise
no one has actually told me why I'm in
Berlin or what I'm doing something about
Captain America going crazy this is your
neighbors we're not roommates sure okay
you got what the hell you're wearing my
suit where's the case okay that's not
Martin what I thought that was a closet
this is still marvel
please my room is way bigger than that
hi I found the case I found the case you
found the case minor upgrade oh my god
put it on what this is the coolest thing
I said let's go I don't understand is it
for me happy happy wait this is insane
insane look at this thing look look at
the eyes
mr. gray today my life okay I gotta go I
gotta go
okay so the previous thing just happen
right like never find the Captain
America I stole his shielding I threw it
at him he's big now I gotta go yeah it's
amazing things ever happen so mr. Stokes
like a ruse and I just sort of flipped
in and I stole cap Sheila's okay what's
up everybody and hey just a second
coming we have thin walls here what is
it a little video diary
that's alright I chose not to do it he
was filming everything I'm gonna wipe
the chip hey you know what we should
actually we should make an alibi a video
for your hand anyways ready get the
frame hey man how you doing what are you
wearing something skimpy I hope that's
an appropriate all right let's start
over you can end of it 3-1 hey May my
gosh I want to tell you what a
incredible job
your nephew did this weekend at the
Stork internship retreat everyone was
impressed it's a frigging merger so this
is cuz you're not at Queens Boulevard
see happiest is hoping to get bumped up
to asset management he was four head of
security and before that it was just a
driver a private conversation
I don't like joking about this it was
hard for me to talk to you no seriously
it was he snorted but alright happy can
you give us a moment you want me to
leave grab Peters case out of the trunk
I can keep the suit yes we were just
talking about do me a favor though
Happy's kind of your point guy in this
dos três amount don't do anything stupid
I've seen his cardiogram alright yes
don't do anything I would do and
definitely don't do anything I wouldn't
do
there's a there's a little gray area in
there and that's where you operate
what does that mean then I'm gonna
vendor though that seventh floor I can
take that up you don't have to take it
you're gonna take it oh yeah I can take
thank you she wins wins her next step
was running retreat you know what next
mission yeah in the mission the missions
will call you do you have my number you
know I mean we'll call you like someone
will call you oh alright fatigue
that's not a hug I'm just grabbing the
door for you we're not we're not there
yet
bye
[Music]
cool
you
[Music]